We Gather at a vital time for the United
Kingdom
these are stormy days
together we've mourned the deaths of
Queen Elizabeth II The Rock on which
modern Britain was built
we're now in a new era
under King Charles III
we're dealing with the global economic
crisis caused by covid and by Putin's
appalling war in Ukraine
in these tough times we need to step up
I'm determined to get Britain moving to
get us through the Tempest and to put us
on a stronger footing as a nation
I'm driven in this Mission by my firm
belief in the British people
I believe that you know best how to
spend your own money to get on in life
and to realize your ambitions
my friends that is what conservatism is
about
it's a belief in Freedom in Fair Play
and the great potential of the British
people
so I'm not going to tell you what to do
or what to think or how to live your
life
I'm not interested in how many two for
one offers you buy at the supermarket or
how you spend your spare time or in
virtue signaling
thank you
I'm not interested in just talking about
things but actually in doing things
what I'm interested in is your hopes and
fears that you feel every day
can you get a good job locally
is it safe to walk down the High Street
late at night can you get a doctor's
appointment
I know how you feel because I have the
same hopes and fears
I want what you want
I've fought to get where I am today
I fought to get jobs
to get pay Rises and get on the housing
ladder
I've juggled my career with raising two
wonderful daughters
I know how it feels to have your
potential dismissed by those who think
they know better
I remember as a young girl being
presented on a plane with a junior air
hostess badge Meanwhile my brothers were
given Junior pilot badges
it wasn't the only time in my life that
I've been treated differently for being
female or for not fitting in
it made me angry and it made me
determined determined to change things
so other people didn't feel the same way
I remember growing up in Leeds where I
saw too many children being let down
let down by low expectations let down by
a labor Council who were more interested
in political correctness than they were
in school standards
but I was lucky to have been brought up
in a family that cared about education
they taught me the value of hard work
and Enterprise
and I stand here today as the first
prime minister of our country to have
gone to a comprehensive School
stop
that that taught me two things one is
that we have huge Talent across our
country and two that we're not making
enough of it
this is a great country I'm so proud of
who we are and what we stand for but I
know that we can do better and I know
that we must do better and that's why I
entered politics
I want to live in a country where hard
work's rewarded where women can walk
home safely at night and where our
children have a better future
to deliver this we need to get Britain
moving we cannot have any more drift and
delay at this vital time
let's remember where we were
when I entered Downing Street
average energy bills were predicted to
soar above 6 000 pounds a year
we Face the highest tax burden that our
country had had for 70 years
and we were told that we could do
nothing about it
I didn't accept that things had to be
that way I knew that in action would be
unconscionable
families would have been unable to heat
their homes
businesses would have gone bust
jobs would have been lost
and we would have worse public services
including the NHS I couldn't allow this
to happen
I refused to consign our great country
to decline
[Applause]